TIME TO PLAY "NAME THAT BARBIE."
GUYS, THERE'S A TUMBLR CALLED
"WEIRD BARBIE PHOTOGRAPHY"
BECAUSE RULE 34.
(LAUGHTER)
IT PHOTOGRAPHS BARBIE IN
SURPRISING POSITIONS.
I'LL SHOW YOU A PICTURE AND FOR
250 POINTS YOU HAVE TO COME UP
WITH A NAME FOR THE DOLL.
READY?
LET'S START WITH THIS ONE.
WHAT IS THAT?
(LAUGHTER)
DOUG?
>> JUMP START BARBIE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: YES!
POINTS!
POINTS.
I WOULD HAVE SAID CAPITAL
FUNISHMENT.
>> OKAY, I'LL GIVE YOU SOME
POINTS.
>> Chris: THANKS, DOUG!
I CAN'T TAKE DOUG'S POINTS.
HE'S IN THIRD PLACE.
NEXT ONE, THIS THING.
LOOK AT THAT.
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
YES, NATASHA?
>> SUPER FUN NIGHT BARBIE.
(LAUGHTER)
WHAT?
>> Chris: I HATE THAT I HAVE TO
GIVE YOU POINTS FOR THAT.
>> ME!
ME!
>> Chris: DOUG?
>> SALACIOUS CRUMB'S B.F.F.
BARBIE.
>> Chris: YOU TITILLATE IT HAD
NERDS IN THE AUDIENCE.
JUST FOR YOU DOUG.
NEXT ONE?
YES, KUMAIL?
>> "(BLEEP) ON MY FACE EITHER
ONE BARBIE."
>> Chris: POINTS FOR SURE!
YOU WANTED TO ADD ONE, NATASHA?
>> "I LOST MY VIRGINITY AT A
PUDDLE OF MUD CONCERT."
>> SHE COULD HAVE JUST SAID I
LOST MY VIRGINITY IN A PUDDLE OF
MUD.
>> Chris: I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU
A HUNDRED POINTS FOR THAT.
I LIKE HOW EXCITED YOU GET.
I'VE GOT TO GIVE YOU 250 MORE
POINTS FOR THAT.
THIS NEXT ONE, GUYS, COME ON.
WHAT'S THAT.
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
DOUG?
>> YOU SHOULD SEE THE OTHER GUY
BARBIE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> WAY TO TAKE THE HIGH ROAD!
250 POINTS!
THE HIGH ROAD!
FUN!
NEXT ONE?
WHAT IS THIS ONE?
WHAT'S THAT ONE?
KUMAIL?
>> FIRE CROTCH BARBIE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: NO, I'M NOT GIVING YOU
POINTS FOR THAT.
NATASHA?
>> ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANT WHO
(BLEEP)S YOUR HUSBAND BARBIE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: DOUG?
>> DOES THE CARPET MATCH THE
DRAPES, BARBIE?
>> 250 POINTS.
>> THAT'S A VARIATION OF MY
BARBIE!
I SAID FIRE CROTCH.
>> Chris: WE ALL HAD RED HAIR TO
DEAL WITH KUMAIL!
COME ON, MAN, DOUG NEEDS THIS!